I'd like to welcome you to this third in
our series of programs about the
changing nature of scholarly
communication the first two sessions are
upon the scholarly communication website
first one our stewardship were talking
about the Harvard's new open access
policy and the second one a a really
interesting panel of people talking
about the impact of scholarly
communications and how you can measure
that so if you weren't able to get to
those sessions really encourage you to
take a look at the videos today we're
focusing on the future of the monograph
and asking our distinguished panel
whether this endangered species will
survive Helen tato is the editorial
director at Fordham University Press
prior to coming to Fordham she was
humanities acquisitions editor at the
Stanford University Press where she was
credited with having transformed quote a
moderately respectable academic press
into a luminous beacon of intellectual
creation Tata has worked in publishing
for over 30 years and frequently
lectures on editing and university press
publishing sandy thought sure who we
hope is on his way from 168 Street and
will be here momentarily has served as
the director of the Penn State
University Press since 1989 and before
that he was at Princeton University
Press and he was editor-in-chief there
for the last four years of his time at
Princeton in 2007 28 he was president of
the Association of American University
presses and he's the recipient of their
award for excellence in publishing he's
a frequent writer and commentator on
open access copyright and university
press publishing reedy donato is
director of the history and humanities
division at the columbia libraries and
she's currently also acting director of
the Burke library at Union Theological
Seminary
prior to coming to columbia we held
public services and collection
development positions in the libraries
at NYU UCSD northwestern and the
University of Chicago in her present
role re manages a very extensive
collections budget for the Humanities
and consequently buys a lot of
monographs we're asking each panelist to
speak for about 15 to 20 minutes as
Katherine said and will then open up for
questions and comments and again if you
can remember to use the mics that will
help us for the videotaping so I'm going
to ask Helen to start thank you very
much to the columbia university
libraries for creating this program and
for inviting me to be part of it i very
much look forward to getting back to my
computer and going online and finding
out what has been done and what is to
come I've heard it said I believe my
dick tournament of UC Santa Cruz out of
the findings of a system-wide Committee
on scholarly research and publishing at
the University of California that eighty
percent of the cost of a book is
independent of whether it appears
digitally or as printed on paper I don't
know whether that's true and if it is
how much it is a function of accounting
and how costs are or aren't allocated
but I thought I'd take as my opening
task today a historical one to say
something about what this money is
paying for about what one's paying for
when one pays for university press
publishing and these things do need to
be paid for rather than expected to pay
for themselves in the discussion period
I could refer to some of the suggestions
and projects that are in in train apart
from the last phrase that all this does
need to be paid for what I will now say
will need multiple Rio tick ulation in
relationship to new media the one should
remember that these usually permeate
production and actual cut our tasks
before they simply replace objects we
hear lots and lots and lots of talks
about well we're going to have
electronic books but what in fact
happens is it copy editors designers
work electronically editors spend all
their time on email rather than writing
letters so these permeate work tasks in
ways that I think don't probably get
focused on as much as they could I hope
that today's pama will be a stimulating
contribution to all this
but I thought it might heart just helped
to start from what on the publishing
side might be taken to be the basics and
I hadn't realized until just now that I
could have actually brought pictures for
you if I'm going to talk about but it's
such a precious object that I keep it in
my home library because I would not know
however how to replace it if I lost it
once upon a time back in the late 50s to
be precise at least some University
presses were big buildings full of
satisfyingly complicated-looking
machines and people with the expertise
to operate them right down to the
ability to cut the dyes for printing a
spying in short they were the printing
plant of the University they printed the
materials such as catalogues needed by
the University they bound books at need
for the library and they had a
commercial good printing and binding
that could be sold outside the
university and for decades I was
fielding calls from people who had
gotten some you know privately printed
book done at the Stanford University
printing plant and paid for it and that
of course went into their coffers but
there wasn't really a university press
book and because of that commercial good
they didn't need subsidies I have a
wonderful brochure from 1959 that shows
stanford university press in this light
and all those machines must have
absolutely delighted an administrators
heart particularly a male administrator
and in light of them the very great
director leon seltzer who started his
career here at Columbia when work on the
Columbia encyclopedia at Columbia
University Press could in its preface
easily refer to printing and publishing
and as I quote mysterious arts with the
advent of computer typesetting in the in
the 1970s those beautiful machines
became obsolete rather than invest three
million dollars in recalibrating them to
new technology that University like most
closed as University Press planning
printing plant then the love-hate
romance of computers and university
presses began as a matter of outside
suppliers often multi-million dollar
businesses I was astonished to discover
how much money one of our main printers
makes in a year who provide what we need
in order to produce our books there
mediatic forms without our universities
having to hire typesetters as employees
of course when is this a in those in
those days in the 50s the Luna type
people the proofreaders the copy editors
were all actual employees of the
University
and from those that time in the early
70s there's been well university presses
were an early part of the sort of waves
of outsourcing that we see everywhere in
the society and now of course there is
the claim that the book will be replaced
in forms that presumably represents
still more revenue in redmond which as I
Cellino is corporate headquarters of
Microsoft and represents still fewer
jobs at home other university presses
such at for such as Florida my present
employer were more virtual from the
outset as is the entire form of
scholarly publishing is an enterprise in
1907 on I think he actually was one of
the Jesuits at Fordham but someone
wanted to publish his own research and
so he started for it and press out of
his living room basically somewhere on
the Upper West Side I think it was but
because it was in New York one didn't
have the need for a printing plant
because there were already places you
know plenty of places this being a
capital of printing for in publishing
for this work to be done outside the
house even where the University Press
was conceived as also a printing plant
from its inception just over 100 years
ago it was from the first conceived as
above all a means of publishing research
and faculty research it is an integral
part of the model of the research
university imported into this country
from the University of Berlin at the
turn from the 19th into the 20th century
and it is linked to the notion that
university presses create new knowledge
also very interestingly and I think this
is key to the whole question of what is
the monograph and is it or is it not
endangered part of that model is that in
the humanities and Social Sciences
professors become authors with all that
means capital a starting with Milton in
this society a very complicated and
fascinating question indeed in seriously
the whole question of the monograph is
kind of hiding the author and the
question of university presses
University of passers is people who sign
over you know works Oh monograph I
actually I didn't bring to this
particular presentation the last talk I
gave when I was asked to talk about a
monographs and that was at MLA and I
defended the notion and looked up what
monograph means monograph means and my
father's one the few people who have
actually written one
it had a precise meaning in the 19th
century and it was a book that gave
everything that was known about a
particular biological species the second
meeting that webster's new 11th
dictionary which is our dictionary
reference gives is and I wish I
remembered to write it down and bring it
here today it's totally disparaging you
know a narrow book that nobody would be
interested in basically so it isn't
technically a term of opprobrium if you
look at websters and i don't think our
authors write books like that nor do i
think our professors write books like
that scholarly publishing now touch just
a little bit on it economics and we can
be detailed in the discussion if you'd
like scholarly publishing is not about
making money I have repeatedly made the
point that putting a price on a book and
unless one is Cambridge erbil Brill one
prices to the market rather than to
cover the overall cost of look I've had
the head sir Tony whoever at Cambridge
lean forward with his very Oxbridge
accent say we didn't realize what our
books were worth well no hey realize how
badly they could screw libraries oh but
putting a price on a book it's not a
statement of intention to make a profit
rather on it represents an openness
within the institutional situation of
any given university anyone with what is
in comparison with tuition even for a
relatively poor institution like Fordham
a relatively small amount of money can
own a physical printed book and thus
participate in the work of learning
taking place at the University whose
name is printed on its spine even in
faces places physically remote from that
University in its classroom I mean this
is at the core of publishing this
obsession and delight with dissemination
and here I suspect were maybe a little
bit different from librarians who are
our I was possibly concerned with
preservation issues more than we are I
mean somebody tears the book up fine
they can find another one even within
the university itself a university press
book is what is technically called a
positional good its value lies not in
how much money one can get for it but in
the rankings that can secure for its
author and its publisher and that
quality of positional good extends to
the remote procedure purchaser who by
winning it participates in the
university's on prone positioning the
last time I spoke about books was at
Michigan and I I did it all out of
markets in a book I'd published that was
taking apart the idea of capital d
capital M market by looking at how
markets actually function as a matter of
particular communities and actually
there's a wonderful chapter in it on
show dogs at the market and show dogs or
sherlocks as a market and comparing that
to literary scholarship a show dog is a
positional it's a positional good it's
you can't make a lot of money off it but
you've got the best dog you can be
really proud of having the best dog and
thus improve if you've got the well as
Colombia does an English professor was
just tenured and won the Renee well
Accord which is the biggest complet
award in the country last year but back
to the question of what one is paying
for in paying for a university press for
one thing one's paying for people like
me I'm an acquiring editor this means my
job is to recognize value and create
reputations to assess or better to
orchestrate the assessment of we are
very much a matter of networks in in
editing the value of scholarly work and
to create the reputation of a university
press from the institutional angle that
is from the viewpoint of creating the
reputation of a press this is a matter
of what I call constellation I arranged
for books to be accepted for publication
and to be seen together in ways that
bring out the value of each in
relationship to others and one hopes
make each see more than it would be on
its own I had a colleague in marketing
once who said at the MLA what I'd really
like at a conference like this is to
have the one book that all ten to
fifteen thousand people here want a
nightmare apart which you want to be you
want you want people to feel like a
community but then you'd be in the
situation that Louisiana was when it
published confederacy of dunces and if
you have a huge bestseller in your small
presence not really great because all
your systems are strained besides I also
that's very trade book thinking that you
throw away all the books that don't make
money for the one big one that will and
you push to millions of people and we
don't think that way in University Press
published
um this is also a matter of diplomacy
this building of reputations and
constellation of using the system of
scholarly communication to create a
sense of community though a community of
openness of exposure to new ideas rather
than rien scription into received ones I
was back in the 80s that the very great
driven media scholar free Jewish kittler
who was an author of mine jokingly said
that the University Press is the
Diplomatic Service of the university but
I gather that the Provost of SUNY Albany
is now saying the same thing from his
experience with the Naval Institute
press but well actually even for
institutions like Stanford in Columbia
particularly for Stanford when i first
started acquiring for them it was really
difficult to convince an assistant
professor on the east coast to publish
with the west coast press the west coast
was it looks a little like when i was in
college in the 70s it wasn't really
quite considered legitimately an
intellectual part of the country now i
think that's changed but it took a lot
of work and for university like Fordham
Catholic schools are sometimes seen and
what I think of as anthropological time
you know people act as if theology was a
discipline that happened you hundreds
and hundreds of years ago and in fact
there are lots of extremely interesting
theologians working right now so I see
you know what I'm doing there what
university presses are doing our
underlying the whole system of
scholarship but also working in this
task of reputation building which is so
important to universities from the
author side which is more fun when
actually both fun but my friend and
colleague bill germano once turned the
editors role enlightened interference by
which he meant working to shape an
individual scholars thoughts for a
market and he had a very it sounded in
this essay which I published and
actually one of my books as if he had a
very strong idea that he knew what a
market was and the author didn't however
attended to the fact that teaching a
freshman class has probably in most of
our authors experiences already been
rather more effective in that regard I
gather they just sit there and look at
you look OH if you can't get through to
them I prefer to tell the story of an
editor otherwise so let me offer an
anecdote I don't have a picture but I
can have a story oh the director of a
major university press
end of add a long interview once to ask
me what sort of editor I am I was rather
taken aback since at the time who I am
as an editor had been attested to by an
international letter-writing campaign of
many months but i guess that meant that
thee well actually it was quoted to my
embarrassment somebody really did and i
was terribly moved by many many things
like with what was quoted were said but
the directors background was in the
sciences and so on sighs and understands
the funds in humanities I told him about
an author formally at his own
institution about that of that
University Press I was major book I'd
encouraged for more than a decade from
brilliant pilot article finally to
publication at 484 pages we did manage
to conceal the title of this referred to
only five years of the major authors
life if he was discussing it was a very
fine book however during this time I had
been about as interferential in bills
terms as I could manage offering the
author repeated sets of comments on his
drafts copying the editing the book
myself and sending him a 40 page memo of
comments and suggestions with the
editing when the manuscript finally
returned from his review of editing with
a delay of many months while the package
languished in the warehouse because the
author hadn't put my name on it with the
result that was taken to be returned
merchandise I didn't realize until I
wrote this out yesterday morning that's
a little the operations of the
subconscious here shortly realize that
the author hadn't read a word of my
lengthy and sympathetic memo which of
course i had spent many many hours on
how deflate he said the major university
press director at this point no we
haven't reached the end or even the
point of the story i replied once the
book was published the author wrote me a
very beautiful beautiful letter offering
gratitude on first seeing the book to me
above all for simply being there asking
him year after year about his progress
on him making him feel that he was an
author another author of mine Judith
Butler has given this function to me in
book than at fordham in the following
terms which I find very moving um and I
quote her if I am to give an account of
myself it is always to someone to one
whom I presume to receive my words in
some way although I do not and cannot
know always in what way in fact the one
who is positioned at the receiver may
not be receiving at all may be engaged
in some
that cannot under any circumstances be
called receiving doing nothing more from
me than establishing a certain site and
position a structural place with
relation to a possible reception is
articulated um I just couldn't believe
it you know I was editing this cross
like it with my cat in my lap and
learning and this is what I have said
about being an editor for decades of
decades Judith is describing the basic
situation of any human being but it's a
very beautiful description of the
structural position in which the editor
is and and this opens again the whole
question of what an author is why should
getting an account of oneself be part of
what one is asked to do as a humanities
professor that goes into the very notion
with a professor in the strong sense of
one who professes you know who witnesses
who gives oneself to a discipline you
know what does that have to do with
books it's really interesting and and
actually endangered at the moment given
they for rise of poor profit
universities question quickly since my
time is drawing to a close I have always
said that the decision to publish a book
is the decision to give to it the work
of various other people copy editors
typesetters designers and still others
the status of these heirs of the people
pictured when 1959 brochure is probably
what it most is is probably most at
stake in today's discussion of the
future scholarly publishing and of a
monograph you know are you is it really
going to become a book in the sense that
all one pays for the time of these other
people to be given to it here if invited
in the discussion I could offer longed
aggressions about the gnomes of Redmond
and how they create a false sense of
freedom while concealing yet yet
intensifying the ways our intellectual
production in fact our very lives are
bound in to me d attics social networks
while also enriching to observe extremes
those involved in propagating the
meeting the medium of the computer via
endless campaigns of planned
obsolescence and I might say while those
involved in the traditional skills of
publishing such as copy editors however
on the verge of financial ruin though
now we all do but we've known this was
coming and publishing for especially
people in California for some decades in
short
flex technological dance Microsoft tries
to offer you freedom from the whole
social system of publishing it always
looks like you could all do it yourself
and then we have to pay someone $25 an
hour to undo it I remember with intense
annoyance coming across a little lie on
the part title that one of my thing of
translator / editors had done I finally
I couldn't figure out how to get rid of
it and I tried and tried I finally just
said you're younger than me you have to
figure out why did you put it there in
the first place another thing about
computers is people never read
instructions anymore they futz and so
you give them careful guidelines saying
please for God's sake don't use any of
these format things that you know just
how to do it nobody reads it for a
second and then of course you have to
pay a copy editor get get the manuscript
the way you want it so that it can be
cleaned up and then type set as a book I
see decima that can comment on that but
spell checks are no substitute for
proofreaders though they often catch
things that proofreaders don't and the
covers created by train designers in
multiple subtle ways go far beyond what
any author could create on her own and
we see that all the time and all these
will come with a grade I deal but to
really know typography it looks
different it looks like somebody's spent
time on it it looks like it's removed
from you into a realm of social value
that's what publishing is which is what
I'm about to say um and then there's the
whole question of publication of making
public in short of marketing the
inquiring editors work of constellation
like the author's work in simply writing
the book comes to completion and all the
depressed does and it is work by trained
professionals that must be paid for
designers make about 75 dollars an hour
i wish i did in creating catalogs ads
postings on amazon and barnes and noble
figuring out how what discount is
necessary since I see a marketing
director in the audience to get Amazon
to you know do their little if you buy
this book you could buy this book with
it I don't know but somebody figured it
out it's really important in publishing
books this all this work finally pulls
the books out of the nooks and crannies
of the author's imagination and anxiety
and fear of tenure and promotion issues
and presents it with full fetishistic
aura quoting marks or phrased in
positive terms with the patina achieved
by the Polish of many hands
as a commodity a positional good I
haven't here even attempted some of the
bridging to digital media although I've
just heard a little bit though media
history is actually favorite topic of
mine but let this be an opening gambit
and I'm sure you want to listen someone
else by now thank you very much it's
great to be back at Columbia again my
father actually graduated from Columbia
University in 1918 and a classmate of
his was Oscar Hammerstein back in those
days you have a more recent graduate
who's gained something Barack Obama and
I happen to share a birthday with him so
I can claim some connection there but I
actually spent a year graduate school
here in philosophy 1965 to 1966 and
perhaps the highlight of that experience
was a seminar taught by Joel Feinberg on
the theory responsibility and a fellow
graduate student and that seminar was
dairy perfect and those who know perfect
will appreciate that the rest of us in
the class simply SAT back and watched
Parfitt and Feinberg go at each other in
this Sarah high-level pyrotechnic
electoral exchanges and it was it was
quite a treat but that's a that's sticks
very much in my memory of my experience
at Columbia I just came I'm sorry to be
a little late from a AUP board meeting
of Philadelphia and yesterday we spent
about three hours engaging in what I
might call the hermeneutics of the
Google settlement and as as I'm sure
Kenny and the audience knows there's a
353 page document which we're all
working our way through and those of us
in the APU to feel some responsibility
for interpreting it for the the rest of
our colleagues are going to be spending
the next several months going through it
all line by line and trying to figure
out what it all means but I start with
that because what I'm going to try to do
here is actually distinguish between
what I would call the digitized book
which is what Google is all about the
whole
Google library project google book
search program that's all what I would
call the digitization of existing print
books and contrast that with what I will
call for convenience the digital book
and the digital book is I think perhaps
best exemplified by a project that was
based here right at Columbia and that's
Gutenberg II and I thought it might be
appropriate today to actually talk about
that project and to really distinguish
it from the the economics of the the
digitized book contrasting it with the
economics of the digital book because I
think the digital book is in interesting
ways on the potential future of the
publishing scholarly monograph but it
involves huge challenges as the
Gutenberg II project discovered i I've
actually written an article about this
which will appear in the
january/february issue of against the
grain I haven't finished it all yet but
I kind of give you preview that and what
I'm integrating into it are started out
with the melon report annual report
which came out in July where Don waters
and colleague has their talked about
various of the melon projects and what
they said about the Gutenberg II project
disturbed me because they talked about
in terms of mostly a failure in contrast
with JSTOR which is you know the the
jewel in the crown of the melon
foundations project and secondarily also
well thought of theirs is project muse
of course both of those were focused on
journals and then they have the
Gutenberg II project focused on books
which they considered more or less you
know only a modest success at best and
part of the reason for that is that they
the chief criterion which they by which
they judged it in that melon report is
economic sustainability well happens
that I was on the the committee that
advised Robert Darnton about setting up
this project in the first place so what
I've done in a post-mortem on the
Gutenberg II projects go back and look
at what those it was talked about before
the project ever got off the ground
that happens in cave wittenberg who was
the person who actually managed the
project for Columbia the press and
libraries Elm actually has written her
own article about this which will appear
in the january/february issue of learned
publishing and we exchanged articles and
turns out that there are very
complimentary because what I do is
concentrate on the background which he
does is concentrate on the actual
lessons learned what what happened in
the project and sort of what conclusions
you can draw from it and my take on it
really goes back to the talks we had a
Princeton University Press well really
beginning in the early 1970s when on the
director associated director and the
another colleague there ro series of
articles for journal scholarly
publishing about the crisis in scarlet
communication and there were 33 articles
there and and they were quite
influential at the time as kind of
recognizing that we really had problems
with publishing monographs and at
Princeton in particular I was the
acquiring editor for Latin American
Studies among other fields in Latin
American Studies was one of the fields
which we began to call an endangered
species and I think that term really
originated with her Bailey the director
there who previously been a science
center to the press and I think he liked
to think in those kind of biological
terms so we talked about these
endangered species and began discussing
them with the people that melon Jack
Sawyer was the prevalent time and her
bailing he talked quite a bit and then
after Jack solar stepped down the person
who became that President melon was Bill
Bowen had been president Princeton
corson had sat on the board of trustees
at the press and of course it had a lot
of contact with the press so we had
talked these issues through with with
dell bowen extensively with jack sorry
before him and with robert darn and
Robert Darnton had been a member of the
editorial board at the press and I had
had many luncheons with him to talk
about these issues over over time and he
was particularly interested not just
because he was a scholar but he was a
scholar of book history so naturally
took a special interest in sort of the
future of the book because he still had
studied the past of the book all
way up to that point so he had a special
concern as a scholar in these issues as
well as just you know being a sort of
representative scholar and general
concerned about the fate of the
monograph and so we we talked about
these issues over a period of time and
you know I think Darton learned these
lessons pretty well and he at the early
in 1998 he summarized the plight of the
monograph in in a in a letter that he
sent out which was kind of an early
draft of the proposal for melanin and as
he said three interlocking problems
bedevil our profession the sky rotting
skyrocketing price of journalists has
decimated library budgets and produced a
disastrous drop in purchases a monograph
the drop in demand from libraries has
made universities cut back drastically
on the publication of monographs and
reaching Pete recent PhDs are finding it
fiercely difficult to advance into
careers by converting their
dissertations into books so that was its
quote I said with allowance for certain
rhetorical flourishes like decimated
disastrous drastically fiercely
difficult which word art and zone
invention this was a nice lease extinct
description of the pattern that the ARL
had documented statistically for many
years to show the painful effect of the
spiraling of STM journal prices on the
purchases of monographs by arrow
libraries and that you know that that
graft the aerial updater from time to
time was you know it's become a classic
in the field is demonstrating that
relationship it's very interesting also
now in with with dart ins a ascension to
the head of Harvard's library you can
you can sort of see some of the roots of
a sinking gear and in particularly his
sort of passion for open access because
in this original proposal darton in fact
envisioned that quote the book should be
made available to any reader without
charge perhaps the aaha could publish
directly from its office or via the H
net might be possible to include
document materials a supplement the main
body of the text and all the publication
will be free there should be copyright
protection concerning the republication
the text well lo and behold of course
after
guttenberg e project was winding down
what happened they turned over the the
the electronic files to Columbia
libraries and they're available free so
I mean the darkness original idea for
this in fact turned out to be the end
result of the project after having gone
through this whole process of trying to
build a sustainable economic model for
publishing these things and I say her if
cost recovery is a no media concerned to
Darton and what would motivating him and
proposing gutenberg a one hint comes
from this section the original proposal
quote principle behind the prize would
be to sanction electronic publishing by
showering the winners with so much honor
the tenure committees and academic
administration's would sit up and take
notice if successful the example would
spread and help change the rules of the
game in academic life it could also
promote scholarly communication of a new
kind at a time when publishers and
librarians are perplexed about how to
take the first steps in the difficult
and dangerous field of electronic
publishing end quote the last Darton
strategy underestimated the entrenched
power of traditional academic practices
and his melons post-mortem observes this
aim of the project was never realized
beyond a very limited extent the ebooks
were all but ignored by professional
review media and few of the authors gain
tenure or even got in the tenure track I
might say that the aah a's own post
mortem report is is a bit more
optimistic on both those counts in fact
the H a report says that two-thirds of
the 35 authors whose books would be
published and a good and brig e project
have had either gotten tenure around a
tenure-track so which is not which is
actually a little better than the
average in the field Corey Maj what was
particularly interesting to me in this
is that in our luncheon discussions I
had mentioned an article that I had read
by Cornell librarian Ross Atkinson and
appeared in the college and research
libraries in Bay 1993 it was entitled
networks hypertext and academic
information services some longer range
implications and there what he
elaborated was was a whole new model for
taking full advantage of the electronic
techno
publish a new kind of book and we might
even not call it a book but but his idea
was or what he used the term to describe
as concentric stratification this is how
he described which might consist of a
top level that would contain some kind
of extended abstract this level or
stratum would then be connected to the
next level and so on each succeeding
level would contain the information in
the previous level but would provide an
addition greater degrees of substance in
detail scholarly communications it would
require an extended context and would
therefore deserve a monograph in the
paper environment would in the online
environment merely include more levels
than would a communication that would in
a print environment have been published
as a journal article so as hindered here
Atkinson sees electronic publishing
breaking down the dichotomy between
monographs and journal articles and he
also sees reading shifting from a linear
form to something that is done so to
speak in three dimensions yes these are
his words again first one can read
horizontally or linearly within any
level of a given publication second one
can read vertically or hierarchically
through the levels of any particular
publication and third one can read
referential e back through the
constituent citations be these explicit
or implicit into other texts in the
network end quote it struck me that this
approach could open up wonderful
opportunities to make available often
esoteric research to a variety of
audiences arranging filet people and
journalists wanting basic information
about new research results in
down-to-earth language to highly trained
specialists who want to be last detail
including references to data on which
the results reported or base and
everyone in between now if this were to
become the future path of scholarly
publishing I could readily envision
roles for university editors reference
librarians and public information staff
not to mention computer experts to play
in creating such multifaceted
multi-layered documents well now if that
language that description seems are
somewhat familiar to you it's no
accident because in March 1999 Robert
darn wrote it a now classic article
called the new age of the book for the
New York Review of Books and this is his
description
of what he thinks the ideal monograph
would be not advocating the sheer
accumulation of data are arguing for
links of data banks so-called hyperlinks
these can amount a little more than
elaborate form of footnoting instead of
bloating the electronic book I think it
possible to structure it in layers
arranged like a pyramid the top layer
could be a concise account of the
subject available have perhaps in
paperback the next layer could contain
expanded versions of different aspects
of the argument not arranged
sequentially as a narrative but rather
as self-contained units that feed into
the topmost story the third layer could
be composed of documentation possibly of
different kinds each set off by
interpretive essays the fourth layer
might be theoretical or
historiographical with selections from
previous scholarship and discussions of
them the fifth layer could be pedagogic
consisting of suggestions for classroom
discussion and a model syllabus and a
six-layer could contain readers reports
exchanges between the author and the
editor and letters from readers who
could provide a growing corpus of
commentary as a book made its way
through different groups of readers a
new book of this kind would elicit a new
kind of reading some readers might be
satisfied with a study of the upper
narrative others might also want to read
vertically pursuing certain themes
deeper and deeper into the supporting
essays and documentation still others
might navigate an unanticipated
direction seeking connections that suit
their own interests or reworking
material in the constructions of their
own in each case the appropriate text
could be printed and bound according to
specifications of the reader the
computer screen would be based used for
sampling and searching whereas
concentrated long-term reading would
take place by means the conventional
printed book or downloaded text so
obviously there's there's a real genetic
connection between these ideas when I
talked to Bob about this and showed on
the draft of this he said yeah I simply
forgot you know that this article was
there and what obviously he did
elaborated and some more nuances and and
in following in his own research he is
in fact publishing a book on you know
publishing in France which is you know
another iteration of his was a career
project in which he's going to produce
this kind of multi-layer document I
think Oxford is publishing it but it's
it's getting close to completion and he
described it in fascinating terms in a
in
guttenberg lecture he gave a few years
ago the good bird prize lecture um it's
really going to be terrific book and
this will be you know probably the
preeminent example that this kind of new
new type of book realizing the
possibilities of the medium fully with a
good and Brady project as you know the
word the mellon Foundation actually
accepted the proposal that had been
vetted by our group and they set up two
things one was the the Gutenberg II
project which was as you know was aimed
junior scholars that junior scholars
would each get 20,000 as a grant up
front they would have a year or more
does it turned out a lot more to revise
the dissertations and turn it into this
new kind of book and columbia university
press would published it and the other
one was aimed at more senior scholars
that was called the ACLS history book
project originally now has mutated into
the ACLS humanities ebook project and
and that was really to draw on more
senior scholars work and to get them to
to develop and works of that innovative
variety in in their own fields and to
sort of lead the way by example you know
if the senior scholars would do this
then darton figured that others would
follow in their footsteps and you know
that project was supposed to a produced
in cooperation with university presses
Michigan library supposed to produce 85
books it's only produced I think about
55 and the economic success of that
project has rested very heavily on the
500 more digitized backlist books which
presents contributed to it making an
aggregate which itself was attractive
for libraries to license the the
Achilles heel of both these projects in
a way was the small number of these new
books in a case of the good and bergie
project a total in the end it was
supposed to be 30s is going to be 35
when it's all wrapped up in the ACLS
project looks like they're you know they
may eventually reach 85 but it's still a
very small corpus relative to what's
available the interesting thing from my
point when I went back and look at the
notes about what our advisory group had
told Darton about this there was real
uniform agreement of that this was not
going to be economically sustainable
that you know there's no way in which
this kind of process would be I mean
Melin actually thought that this was one
way of experimenting to see if books
could be published more cheaply online
than than print but those of us who knew
enough about what went into producing
these these very high level fancy
electronic techs realized that the costs
involved in there went far beyond what
it would cost you to publish in
traditional print book and in anti
oakerson who is another member of that
committee also had some very interesting
arguments about the ways in which the
the five different goals that were the
project was supposed to have were
actually inconsistent with each other in
the interest of time I'm going to just
read because I think it's such a good
summary Colin what Colin day had to say
about you know what's involved in this
kind of process and why it's so
expensive so they began by emphasizing
importance of keeping market and
economic considerations and mine design
the project even while admitting that
University presses have evolved to
provide a unique and valuable mix of the
altruistic in the economic and that a
university press in contrast a
commercial publisher decides to publish
in scholarly grounds and then attempts
to make the best economically of the
work whereas the commercial house would
merely decides and economic grounds he
then went on to discuss the important
value added by presses in the editorial
work they perform continuing he said
quote so far I've treated the work as
though it could be thought of as a
manuscript as a linear text however
there are many more potential dimensions
to the electronic publication and these
complexities blur the distinction
between the editing I have been
discussing so far and the more detailed
and technical issues that demand
attention for the electronic publication
what is new the electronic environment
difficult to generalize about as the
work does require not to ensure the
digital elements work but to design the
publication to develop the look and feel
to exploit the technology effectively to
ensure that not just is a simple text
but in this new medium the work is an
effective vehicle conveying its men
to its intended readership this is an
expensive exercise costing much more
than analogous analogous activity in the
traditional medium may well be that for
the kind of scholarly works under
consideration for the prize the work
should be envisioned only is text
delivered electronically that is without
these costly efforts however it is by
showing the capabilities of this median
and showing them well that the prestige
which is the end objective of the whole
exercise will be achieved simpler
complex they remain the questions of who
manages the work and who pays for we are
i assume focusing our works it would not
be economic publishing traditional codex
form so the full cost of traditional
publication would be higher than the
likely revenue now electronic
publication of a straightforward text
may be a little cheaper than traditional
so there is a category of work that may
be viable electronic form that is not
viable traditional form but the category
I believe is a small one carefully
restricting a competition to such works
unit we could assess lead enta Phi the
max ante would seem rather artificial
not in the spirit of the project it
would eliminate many worthy candidates
it would not be fully viably even with
the modest cost savings of electronic
publication thus we have to plan on the
basis that winners will not generate
sufficient revenue to cover costs this
is certainly true if their works exploit
the technology and have rich hyper
textual linking and multimedia elements
embedded again the cost of designing
implementing such devices and checking
them for reliability are significant so
I see an inescapable need for funding to
support these tasks of publication I've
not mentioned the questions about
controlling access copyright collecting
payments etc which all raised questions
about the income flow and such
electronic publishing although I am
moderately sanguine about the
establishment of long-term solutions to
all these problems any scheme designed
today should presume that revenue from
electronic book using the term book
elastically but excluding the repetitive
subscription-based publication the
journal type will be small so I find it
inescapable the project will need
ongoing funding not only for the prizes
and the competition competition
administration but also for the
publication of the winning works and he
goes on to actually describe some more
detail about what kinds of cross are
involved and in her summing up Kate
Wittenberg in her own postmortem
acknowledges that one of the most sort
of one of the lessons learned here is
that the production of these works is
truly a collaborative effort it's not
the single scholar going off and just
producing the work that the scholar
involved in these projects the in fact i
headed extra melon from money from melon
in order to set up workshops because the
scholars once they got the $20,000
didn't know quite what to do I mean even
how to begin so Columbia actually had
workshops who the technologists the
editors and the scholars all involved
and it turns out that the production of
these books involved that kind of
collaboration throughout the entire
process which meant of course there was
a very expensive process not just
involving a single scholar but an entire
team producing each of these books and
and and and you know that that really is
is kind of at the core of why these
books are so expensive to publish there
they are she has a very interesting idea
towards the end of her own horse modem
modem about the need for developing
templates so that perhaps you know
publishers could sort of agree that
perhaps there may be 10 templates that
could be designed so so that you know at
least the majority of these books could
flow through some kind of controlled you
know process which would cut down the
cost because they would you know have
sort of set designs and set approaches
for them that's kind of thing of course
would of course be costly to set up an
advancement to take time to develop
those templates but I do think that's
one possible approach to eventually
keeping the cost of these projects lower
than they would otherwise be because in
the Gutenberg II project turned out that
each each of these projects was a
project all of its own and they had to
devise new approaches and do new things
for each of the project so it was you
know custom-made book in a sense and
that is very expensive way to publish so
i'll conclude just here by just saying
that um you know I in my own mind I
think that the true future of scholarly
monograph publishing in the ideal world
is to produce the kind of book that Bob
Darton himself is producing but the the
big red flag here is that I see
see no easy way of doing this you know
without some other kind of model which
would provide the continuing funding for
it and you know I leave that to others
to to devise a hollandaise himself who
was so a student seeing these things as
a PhD in economics from Cambridge so he
had a much better idea of what was going
on here than some of us who didn't have
that kind of professional training so
we'll have some questions I guess later
well my remarks are going to be
considerably more informal and of the
observation type since here to speak
from the experience in the libraries
where yes we are as Patricia said buying
lots of monographs still especially in
the humanities so I don't claim to speak
for the profession or even all of my
colleagues here I hope we'll have a good
conversation as each of you contribute
to what we've heard today we've heard a
little bit about what the scholarly
monograph is and in its print format I
think we're fairly comfortable with what
that represents whether it's a single
author volume or collection of essays or
proceedings and I would agree with sandy
that most of the ebooks that we are
buying our digitized versions of a print
text as opposed to a true digital entity
but it still could be a monograph
whether it is print or e so for the
purposes of my few comments i'm not
talking about reference works or other
kinds of things but what we would
otherwise understand as the scholarly
monograph and i would say that while the
title of today's panel was to discuss
the future of the print monograph in
light of digitization of scholarly
communication i would say at least at a
place like columbia and many research
libraries in academic institutions
scholarly monograph is still valued and
it has its place it is a means of
communication it is recognised it
carries a lot of authority we've heard a
little bit about its place in the
author's creative life about its place
in promotion and tenure I would say it
has a great place still in teaching we
in the library world can observe that
just by looking at our course reserves
collections that we maintain on a
semester by semester level where there
is a lot of electronic material coming
on board but we have healthy collections
of ink on paper sitting on shelves that
we hope are being used the scholarly
monograph to me and my colleagues in the
humanities areas still has quite an
important place in research we see
circulation of them we see borrowing
through other libraries we see the
bibliographies that appear in
dissertations and so we know that in the
research process our scholars are still
using the monograph as well as they are
creating them and in turn then libraries
as the consumers of these monographs I
feel are still having quite a
responsibility and an enjoyment of
collecting them and building collections
and representing these in our resources
i would say in all disciplines and again
i hope that some of my colleagues in the
sciences and Social Sciences or here but
all disciplines do still use the
monograph in some form or other I think
that a lot of the electronic information
that we see our users come to can be
independent and an end in itself but a
lot of times the electronic drives the
use of print materials and monographs
especially you might see something refer
to it may or may not be available
electronically you as the individual
researcher may or may not want to take
that next step and go and actually find
that source but I think in our academic
areas that does happen a lot of times
I would say to further that at least in
the humanities and history disciplines
there still is an expectation of our
faculty our graduate students and our
undergraduates that a library is a place
to go and find the print monographic
material I don't know how much book
buying is done by individuals these days
in terms of thinking of a typical
undergraduate buying their readings for
their courses you talk to go through the
bookstore they they still devote a lot
of floor space to that so there's a
there is some of that happening but I
think there is this expectation that
libraries can serve that role by having
these collections available we may no
longer have everything or not that we
ever did but I'm by that i mean we may
not try to be as comprehensive as we
used to be because we have good networks
through our partners in the Ivy League
and in research libraries across the
country through interlibrary loan and
other kinds of borrowing and lending
services like our own borrow direct but
I think we still fulfill that role based
on the expectation of our users that
libraries will acquire these items and
they will be available how we go about
buying monographs I think in some ways
that may be changing over the years and
when it comes to the print monographs I
think many libraries as we all know in
the audience are reliant often on
approval plans and in other kinds of
ways to make sure that we're keeping up
with the current print publication world
when it comes to the current electronic
publication world I think libraries are
still in a place where we are less
aggressive or less able to acquire
things on a title by title basis and
more reliant on packages of electronic
real so if you want to think of approval
plans for print materials as a way to
package a lot of publications and feel
confident that they're coming in we
might think of some of the packages of
electronic books as doing a similar
thing for us to allow us to bring them
into our collections I think that as
individual electronic books are
integrated in the way libraries
typically acquire things that will be a
benefit to us and to our users but I
don't think that's been worked out quite
as smoothly as we would hope in all
cases I think that in certain subject
areas within the university not
everything can be acquired in these sort
of streamlined ways and so even the
print monograph it's it's harder to
track things down when print runs are
shorter if you're not right there in
terms of submitting your order things
may not be quite as readily available
and enter your collection the way it
might have once done so we have to be as
librarians we have to be very active
about seeing how we're going to find
these publications and bring them into
our libraries we heard a little bit
about the ACLS humanities ebooks
database and there are a number of other
databases and again I think at least
within the humanities we are not in an
either/or situation in terms of the
scholarly monograph in terms of either
print or electronic pick one or the
other and that's it there may be some
subject disciplines that we are aware of
where the preference for electronic is
there and the need to have that print
copy also on the shelf is of lesser
importance again I would say that in
some of the humanities disciplines maybe
even in some of the social science
disciplines that not that's not
necessarily the way to go so as
proponents of the monograph or as
consumers who are keeping its survival
going I think that's one of the reasons
why I would say that the print monograph
is is not completely on its way out at
least within our academic environments
but it is struggling and it's struggling
not because of the quality of what's
being published or the amount of what's
being published but i think it's
struggling based on what you heard from
our earlier speakers about the pressures
on on budgets on the presses budgets to
put the resources into bringing these
titles to publication and we just heard
whether it's print or e if it's quite an
enormous resource that needs to go into
that and i would say that even as
libraries are looking at their budgets
and apportioning certain amount to
serial publication certain amount to
electronic certain amounts to print
monograph it's always been a balancing
act or sometimes a competing act and i
think that we're seeing that still the
complication now is we have a whole new
sort of format and world to be acquiring
whether it's digital backfiles of
journal runs or whether its current
electronic books and so that i think is
having an impact on how we are able to
keep up as libraries in supporting the
monograph in our collections i think
that to my observations have led me to
believe that models for pricing coming
from our publishers have been fairly
known in the print world but these
models / pricing haven't always been
quite as understandable to us in the
electronic world so if material is going
to be born digital or be that ideal
digital book not a digitized version of
a print book I think we have to see
where those price models are going to
take
and how we will be able to continue to
afford to add those to the collection
and keep affording to add print
materials to the collection that we see
as valuable so these were my brief
observations based on the the library
view of where the monograph is right now
and i would say that within the
humanities in history realm there again
is still an expectation that this
material will be in libraries i think
there's still an expectation that
publishers will be out there looking for
quality material to bring to the
scholarly community i think at the same
time there is an interest in moving into
the area of the true digital book
something that takes advantage of all of
the features and technology that's there
a question that that I would raise as we
do this is how do you maintain the life
of that work overtime because you can
create something in a digital form that
needs to survive and how do you do that
when the platforms change and the
technology changes the advantage of a
physical book has been that we've done a
pretty good job at preserving it at
least for a long enough time and making
it something that can last and can be
used in the future I think whether it's
a digitized version of a print book or a
true digital book we don't have all
those answers yet we don't have them in
the preservation world we don't even
have them in the interactive world how
will we make sure those links are still
there or that multimedia still plays or
that interactivity is is going to
continue so that's a new question that I
think will take a team of collaborators
and creators from the authors from the
publishers and even from libraries and
users to put into that so I would end my
quick observations by saying
at least in our foreseeable future while
the print monograph may be threatened in
terms of its place among all these other
types of intellectual resources that
libraries are acquiring it still has a
valued place among those resources and
will still be a desirable resource for
us to continue to collect to make
available and preserve Thank You Rebecca
Kennison center for digital research and
scholarship as most of you know I'm I
was really very interested to hear that
takes that each of you had from the
editorial side from a bit of the behind
behind the scenes taking a look at what
works what doesn't work from ruiz
library side i'm a production person
myself and all of you touched on
production and to a certain extent in
some ways and i was wondering whether
you could talk a bit about how you see
production remaining the same production
differing and where you think business
models for covering that aspect of the
cost might come into play in terms of
thinking about whether it's a digitized
project or a born digital book where you
think that aspect of things comes into
play i totally agree that the editorial
side those those are known costs to a
certain extent and is there any
difference in the production side when
you get into electronic and digital
publishing do you think that's actually
a question I hope somebody would ask
because that's something I want to
address and didn't have time my
presentation some of you may be familiar
with this book by John Thompson called
books in the digital age and Thompson
has the
the dual role being a media sociologist
at Cambridge University in England he's
also a co-founder and co-director of
polity press which for my money is one
of the top to your academic presence in
Britain what this book does is provide I
think this the single best explanation
of the evolution of scholarly publishing
and as a bonus you also get a very good
explanation of the evolution of college
textbook publishing the contrast between
the two quite different business models
and comparison between what happens in
the US and what happens in Britain
because they actually worked out rather
differently in both of those
geographical settings but he identifies
towards the latter part of the book what
he calls the hidden revolution scholarly
publishing what he means by that is the
the advent of digital printing
technology you need to understand that
the single probably most most huge
obstacle for scholarly publishers has
been the artifact of having to use
offset digital printing because also did
or printing meant that your unit cost
went way down the the greater the number
of copies you so there's always a
temptation for energy to be optimistic
to you know to expect that you would
sell more because in in in in project
making those projections you knew that
the unit costs have come down and that
meant that you ended up with warehouses
full of books that didn't sell for years
and years and of course you're all
familiar with the white sails that
presses have from time to time and
that's because you know everybody was
too often a seeking in reality came to
hit home and you know and all those
books were still in the warehouse well
what digital printing technology is two
things first of all the competition
digital printers compelled the offset
printers to bring their prices down so
used to be in the old days that you
could you couldn't print more fewer than
say seven or eight hundred copies of a
monograph because that's the lowest
number that a offset printer would do
for you in competition with digital
printers they can now do as low as 300
copies for using the offset printing
technology
so you know six seven years ago we
changed our model of Penn State press
and what we do now is we use offset
technology and usually do three or four
hundred copies to prove that technology
to begin with which you know produces
the highest quality book for libraries
of some bindings and the whole works
usually sells out in anywhere between 6
and 18 months and then we use digital
printing technology to reduce the favor
of accent what it means with digital
print printing technologies you don't
have to do a print run of a thousand we
actually start out usually with 200
copies sometimes 100 and we reprint in
sort of that range as often as the sales
sustain it once it gets below 50 copies
a year annually we put into what we call
pure p.o.d and that means sending it
some company like lightning source which
will produce books for you you know one
at a time as words come in and so that's
really the sort of the the new economics
of scholarly publishing because it means
you you can now keep your supply much
more in relation to demand you don't
have all this excess stock that you
eventually have to pulk you have much
better cash flow because you don't have
all that capital and tied up in your
inventory and and I think that's the
single best explanation of why scholarly
publishers have been able to survive
because we were all moaning and groaning
around me between 1999 2002 we know well
it was really bad times for university
presses and then this came along and you
know does the skies opened up we all
shout a hello and where we survive for
another you know decade or two who knows
that long but but that's the key and I
think you need to understand that
because for the books that are still
appearing in print these books are
essentially born digital because the
whole processes are our electronic all
the way through to the point at which
you actually get a you know print on
demand book or short run digital print
book but the those digital files of
course can you know be set into eBook
readers and you know
eventually mobile phones is now the new
rage for growing market for these things
so they have multiple purposes and in
the production side as you all know you
know everybody is trying to XML
everything and to you know use the open
ebook standards to try to make possible
the multiple uses of your you know
digital content in all these different
places so that's a very brief summary of
what it's going is this yes this is odd
just to say a little bit about what's up
the line from printing um I think I
tried to refer to these problems in
saying that before you'd have just an
e-book at a different object you have
all of the procedures that people
actually go through changing so that one
edits online nowadays the production is
the designers work online all of these
things are you know computer completely
permeates the work processes and changes
them in some ways now one of the things
everybody knows in just our word
processing processing what's happening
in a word processing is a process of
what back in the 80s and hadia beaudry
arbys call simulation there's a
simulation of what went on in the
lunatic world you know what printing was
like that's why it drives us crazy when
authors think that they're making it
look like a book i actually had authors
say the footnotes look more real if
they're a nine point type when you have
to put the back up to twelve point to
work on them and things like that but
what happens is that simulation is a
really complicated procedure I mean what
what it simulates doesn't go away it
retreats into fine printing and then
what happens is that it starts being
picked up and used in the more real way
and changing it as they say part of this
dance back and forth the presses had to
close down the machines I was talking
about and we went off and used G&S in
Austin and you know that's they there
were people who specialized in
typesetting and then maybe I think it's
within the last ten years people started
bringing so that typesetting back in
in the mellon Foundation project that
were involved with with some of the
people in why you press who are
currently here it's the American
literature's initiative part of what's
being funded is the work of an outside
managing editor who's actually a former
colleague of mine who specializes in
both managing production and doing the
typesetting himself and so various tasks
that we actually we've done by people
from across the border in Mexico who
didn't necessarily know English when we
GNE s was the fine compositor being
brought in house and and done by by
people in house or by people who
specialize in that there has it's my
impression in fact I think it's true
that production costs have come down and
there's a lot of pressure on on people
as sandy was saying to offset printers
to match digital printers there's also
you know competition from India now
although I have you know some
complicated feelings about that about
trying to you know do everything is
offshore as much as possible that's not
new i mean it's been going on for 20 or
30 years trying to use cheaper asian
publishers but is interesting that yes
everything is digital but people talk
about HTML coding i actually don't know
anybody who's actually done it so while
everything exists digitally the movement
from that to some kind of accessible or
usable platform i guess it would be um i
think there's still a certain tentative
list there is that does it give you
something columbia columbia is one of
the first presses to do xml coding in
this production would you
my name is Ken Cruz and although I deal
with copyright issues you are not going
to ask copyright i would i would really
like to hear more about your talks about
the rear and the end of the entire
process what the transformation of the
book means for readers way they acquire
information the way i was very excited
about the quotes from robert dart and i
thought that was great i think that
processes of reading would probably
develop in different ways online and in
the print media people which is one of
the things i had been tempted to write
about I don't know the full jharkhand
that kids have with regard and those
other you know the users of the future
have with regard to what they do but I
think what you do is hit online so that
you know you visit something very
quickly people are very interested in
searches online of course that's a very
very ancient mode it's of concordance of
genre of book and the computer is a lot
better at it than books were my husband
told me this morning as I was coming
here I think it was actually in mellon
project he's involved in with the SSRC
one of the melons suits as he said i
don't know i know i have only his
statement for it so i don't know exactly
what the data came from but apparently
they did some study and found that the
average amount that people who had
online was 13.5 pages um now i happen to
have to moonlight as a copy editor and
my husband works as a copy editor and i
bet a lot of these people who talk about
ebooks don't have to deal with books
online um I actually happen to have been
in disability for computer injuries for
about eight months and was put through
you know very many sophisticated
seminars on the on what I call the other
side in the heart of Silicon Valley and
your eyes are statistically on where the
greatest computer injuries occur it's
there it's difficult there's a problem
of not blinking and there you can't do
anything about it if you have sustained
work on screens you can't have every 10
seconds something say blink if you're
trying to deal with the
king about a sentence in its structure
and we forget about it because it's a
lot of us you know right into computers
your eyes behave pretty passively when
you're writing but when you're reading
your eyes we are very you know you get
stuck to it you also want to wiggle
that's another thing you hurt your
shoulders and back by always being there
so I think that I mean I think that but
that there may come to be a certain
complementarity in reading there's
certain kinds of reading will probably
be developed or return to by means of
electronic things but I'm hoping I
certainly hope because I am attached to
this that the practices of sustained
reading on the efforts of imagination
and whatnot that the book of supports
well I actually I happen to every once
in a while have a 21st century
equivalent of what in the 18th century
they called reading sickness I
periodically love murder mysteries I'm a
total plot addict and I could read about
300 pages in probably maybe four or five
hours if I were doing that on a computer
I'd be sick oh so there it's it's just
reading something very rapid like that
it's not something you can do but there
are many things that you can do very
very well I have heard from exits an
experiment that California is going to
do in the series called flash points um
that's headed by dick tournament my
mentioned in the first line of this his
belief abased on this system wide
committee at UC was that people wanted
in the humanities wanted to search
online and they wanted to read on paper
and I that relates to something Reese
EDD there are a number of statements
coming around from places like project
mused or that that I think what you said
was that the elect electronic drives the
use of print materials because you read
different ways you find out about it
electronically but if you want to if you
want to read it for any length of time
if you want to mark it up if you want to
think with it that all that modes of
reading you probably still do better
looking at a page actually was really
struck I'm doing some reading and
marking at my desk I realized I can hear
the birds and not just which is what I
listened to all day long you know
there's a kind of way in which well you
know that wonderful Yates line that the
long-legged fly moves on silence like
the mind of someone thinking now that
may pass away that there are I've
actually extremely fascinated by the way
in which mediatic changes altered modes
of reading and writing but one just
recognizes that difference I will
mention one amusing thing one place
where electronic things are being we
being adopted I think far faster even in
libraries is in medical imaging and
there are truly in remarkable ways that
I've been shown at actually a seminar I
used to go to it Stanford for how some
virtual means can be used to simulate
what surgeons are going to find but they
found that surgeons lost the ability to
imagine to project as they had had to do
in the past or what might happen when
they cut because they became more and
more dependent on these just throw that
out another dimension of that which I
worry about a lot is what I call a
growing digital divide between book and
journal content because you know you
know project muse and all these as TM
journals are you know readily available
electronically now the books are not in
the books or maybe the google project
you know this new new settlement will
will change that and it does whole
promises of actually bringing a whole
lot more book content online because
what librarians tell us you know you
confirm this is that you know if the
books are not available in electronic
form you can't be searched that way they
don't exist so for publishers of
monographs that's a concern because you
know you also want the journal
literature to interact and preferably
interlink with the book content so you
can you know jump from a link in a
journal article to book
10 not just jump from one journal
article to another journal article and
and that's part probably the Anna speaks
to Kenny's expertise probably the single
greatest obstacle to getting the book
content there is a permissions questions
that the third party rights issues
particularly with images and everything
and that's that's a huge conundrum for
publishers because you know they have to
go back and research what rights they
even have in the digital realm for much
of the content because you know the
contracts they have would written a
pre-digital age they don't know what
rights they actually had to put this
material up in digital form and so you
know there's a huge amount of work even
with the Google settlement that
publishers will have to do to find out
what they can actually put up and book
content and that's going to slow that
you know the digital divide is going to
keep increasing up to a point where that
that problem can be can be resolved if
orphan works legislation is passed that
will you know provide another little bit
of grease to this the wheel of getting
that past that obstacle I can I can just
add one anecdote and another observation
last night I met with the class of
students these were all first-year
students and I and actually their
instructor had given them dart ins
article to read as a way to think about
how they approach the library although
the subject i was helping them research
had nothing to do with that article and
as we were talking about things every
student in the class said well you know
no matter what it is if it's over about
two pages i just printed out I can't
read I can't read on a screen like that
and they said it's you know it's one
thing if I'm reading just for
information or if I'm looking for
something but if I really have to read
it I just print it out and then they
watched into and so why can't we print
out more pages away in the end I thought
that was pretty funny and another
observation I would I would make is I
think in some ways maybe people are
reading more often they're just not
reading in a sort of contemplative or as
you said sustained way because
everything you know if you're on a
computer all the time whether you're
texting or getting emails or you know
doing whatever
you are involved in the act of reading
but I think it's not the kind of reading
that most of us in this room think of
when we say reading so I'm actually
surprised that the average number of
pages is 13 and a half that sounds like
a lot to me when I think of a screen but
I think it will change in this certainly
the device that one is reading
electronic materials on is going to have
a really powerful impact you know
whether it's the kindle or whatever
comes next just the way it sometimes
amazes made to see people watching
movies on their cell phone you know at
some point if you can get the text to
shrink enough but still be aesthetically
pleasing maybe we will do more reading
like that in terms of sheer economics
using a desktop printer to print out the
pages is vastly more costly than
actually you know using a printing press
to produce the paper
Bub's time
and the answers accident to offer to
this question so it gets into the topic
that I wanted to talk about you all
right we talk about very serious
economic challenges but I wonder if
there's also just not a profound as you
inform here that a text that is a
lengthy task that is in a sense of
universe to itself designed to be read
through in some sense from beginning to
end it's not just severely challenged in
an environment where one can you as both
we and Helen have pointed out read
clearly and easily online a text that is
designed to be linked out to other
things a text that is by a textual
environment that's digressive that's
almost attention deprived in some ways
and that one wonders what the fate of a
longer-form like the monograph is in
such an environment I think if nothing
else that means that there's an enormous
pressure on the publishing world to make
sure that the texts that are created or
something one can get into and get out
of quickly and work flexibly and to that
line sandy raised some very interesting
prospects about the speculation of the
exciting things that can be done
eventually with the book but i wonder if
we've not all as a community of
publishers and and librarians demanding
material drop the ball in terms of
getting this very large bulky form into
a much more usable format i as head of
the electronic text service i'm
constantly working with people who are
trying to use the ebook collections we
have online and the content is wonderful
but frankly the usability is very low
and there's been a very low interest in
such things as for example making good
intelligent mining tools supporting
things like proximity operators that let
people jump right into the page they
need presenting let's say a key word in
context display so that people can see
quickly what they have instead of
jumping in a stately fashion from spot
to spot to spot I mean it's clear if if
one is in a discovery rather than simply
reading environment and one has pulled
up fifty books that contain something
when is interested in I suspect no
reader gets past the first five that
contain that material and it seems to me
that some of those tasks are for
caps less exciting but perhaps more
graspable for all of us to look at right
now the ways of crafting books that will
be as easy and comfortable to use online
as the journal articles and I i can say
looking at the state of things today
that's that's not where it is i'm i'm a
great lover of what's in for example the
ACLS project but it's a very very
stately environment it's not one that
lends itself quickly to discovery moving
around and quickly handling those pages
and i think i think there's some
challenges which on one hand are urgent
but on the other hand are quite doable
if the if the publishing world will just
take them on and look a little bit more
closely at usability I don't know what
your thoughts are not our well one of
the big lessons of the Gutenberg II
project is is the inertia of the tenure
and promotion system because that really
drove what happened with that and went
and helped you know parts of it fail I
mean they wanted to get these books
reviewed by professional journals and
professional journals by and large
refuse to do them they didn't know how
to deal with these books eventually they
they produce print galleries and sent
notices to the review media to say this
only represents sort of one part of the
book and you really need to go to this
website to review the whole thing and
the journals were reluctant to do that
aside from the ahr which had sort of a
special recent to to back the project
and did some reviews of some of the
early books it it really was very
difficult to persuade journal editors to
review them at all and you know the
acceptability well yeah tenure promotion
committees you know more or less began
to accept these but it was a struggle
and if you're talking about you know
this is just still identified as a book
and you know there's still the articles
and you're talking about some other kind
of thing like ross atkinson talking
about you know something in between
perhaps or mixtures and whatever a new
creative forms what our ten-year
promotion can be is going to say you
know we as publishers cannot create
these things de novo and sell them into
a market which is not going to accept
them sell
can I just oh sorry and one more
question yeah I find what we have to
talk about very interesting in fact
while you've been speaking I've gone
ahead and purchased the book that you've
mentioned on my phone and what I'd like
to ask is dealing in the Academic Press
environment now what changes are
actively being made for new media
publishing a new media rather than
simply print well one thing we didn't
mention is is what I call a hybrid book
and that's sort of a step in the
direction of you know what Gutenberg II
did but it's it's a it's far from being
the whole distance and at Penn State we
have a romance study series which which
sort of borrowed the model of the
national academies press which they used
for their science publications and what
we've done is put these up on the
library server open access and it's it's
done in such a way that on the chapters
are broken into pdfs half of the pdfs
you can actually you know view online
and then print out download the other
half of the chapters you can view only
on screen and the print function is
disabled there's also a link here to you
know buy this book and it goes to
lightning source and broad you with a
p.o.d copy and so essentially that you
know in national academies press terms
and hours this serves as a kind of
marketing function incites it's like you
know look inside this book it's just
another version of that whereby people
can go in and really sample the content
and just decide about making a book
decision so far it seems to be working
out we're using a template design to
keep the design costs down for this
series the the 22 language departments
at Penn State provide the editorial you
know review processes largely for this
that no cause to the press so you know
there's there's certain ways in keeping
the economics of it lower than some
other monograph publishing but the other
aspect of it is that we we hope to be
able to add various elements to these
for instance
with with respect to these we would like
to provide links or actually digitized
and put up the original French language
positions or Spanish editions of the you
know the texts that are discussed in the
books some other projects we're
intending to do for instance data sets
that social scientists might create we
know we want to put those up so you know
when you buy the p.o.d version of course
you're not going to get those but
they're going to be a you know a linked
and that will be printed in the book so
you can go to this website to get all
this ancillary type of material and it
can be so it can be a full range of and
with illustrated books we publish a lot
in our history you could put a lot of
extra color illustrations up you know
which would be a way to provide a fuller
experience with that particular
monograph without having all the costs
and color illustrations in the book and
sell so that's that's kind of doing a
digital book on the cheap you know it's
moving in that direction but it it's
nothing like the multi-layer to kind of
thing that that dart and book exists so
it bit but it is it is another model
sort of moving in the direction and also
involving elements of open access which
i think is you know we're all feel it's
important for us to experiment with and
you know as long as the the economics
can still support it by selling enough
print copies and we're happy to do it
well I haven't done you know had much
direct experience with this in fact my
first experiment with it may be in part
as a result of being invited to this
panel since I've been talking about the
Senate for digital research and
scholarship about possibly doing our
first experiments in that would be
digitalized books in one case one
possibly might move a bit more toward a
digital book because it actually is the
first book i've come across that's been
written although the author thoroughly
intended it for to be a print book in
ways that ignored the realities of the
page and so we're still working with
designers quite how to do this I mean
she wants to she has a main text but
then she has very lengthy ex curses and
comments that of course she could hit on
you know just click and bring up what we
can't do that in the book because the
designer says well what are you thinking
about that for their six pages
and you've got three lines how you're
going to link that together so we have
yet to we've just be very very very
beginnings of the discussions about how
we can how we can do this but I think
it'll it'll be interesting be
interesting to see how this develops I
mean it probably also will part will
partly take another generation I mean I
I will net never know as much about
computers as people who were 12 years
old you know and I probably wouldn't use
something that was you know available
electronically anyway I might say to the
the previous question here it might be
helpful for there to be some kind of
discussion collaboration with libraries
because you can't just put something out
there you have to be in conversation I
mean the quote i read from judith butler
applies to all aspects of human life
including electronic ones i was one of
the first people in the humanities to
have email at at Stanford because I was
involved with the philosophers and they
were all over the son of her study of
language and information I couldn't use
it because no one would send me a
message you know I couldn't think it up
on my own of course I'm now totaled
email creature but until one of them
could speak my terms enough to write me
a message and have me struggle to answer
back and the things with searches we
probably think it very crude weighs
about searches in comparison people at
libraries I was at the Yale library and
just basically filling in holes in
people's footnotes and I was immediately
having trouble with searches and
librarian says would leave off the last
two letters you know somebody written
down it was a german title somebody'd
written down the endings were all but it
never would have occurred to me so
hopefully there'll be some moment at
which they'll be conversations here and
and more sophisticated tools can be
developed if I could just get one last
question in sandy you mentioned that
we're all trying to digest the Google
settlement
understand how it's going to work on and
even more what the implications are
going to be I'm just and it was
encouraging to hear you say that on a
modest level monographic Publishing's
hanging in there because if the ability
to publish short runs and then print on
demand and so on and wondering if your
colleagues in the University Press
environment are feeling that the Google
settlement may strengthen even more that
ability to get things out there and get
revenues in for monographic publishing
well the great promise of the google
project is is all those out of print
books and the we had a very interesting
discussion they p board meeting
wondering why Google is paying 30
million to the Authors Guild legal team
when you know certainly their expenses
probably at maximum were not more than 3
million so why do they need 27 extra
million said on the other hand you know
there's a real burden on here for all
those presses to research what digital
rights they actually have in all those
out of print books if they haven't
reverted them to authors or you know if
they have reverted dollars and the
authors want to take advantage of it and
you know get them back into print this
way so you know there's a huge amount of
labor that has to go on and and there's
nothing in the settlement to pays for
that labor so we're suggesting take that
27 million you know let's give it to the
presses it actually have to do the labor
you know and we'll do it so okay well
I'd like to just thank all three of our
panelists for really stimulating set of
discussions thank you so much